hour I will I
am I will call this sub committee work
session to
order
um this the subject
is HB
159 uh relative to default service rate
for electricity and energy procurement
plan in the department of energy and
there is an
amendment uh that is being
proposed
um who did you proposed this amendment
the 0557 H um yes 0557 H was the
February Amendment that's correct okay
do you want to speak to that uh I mean
first or actually we need a motion we
need a motion to accept the
amendment make that all
right we have a second I'll second
excuse me I'm taking minutes as well as
trying to run the
meeting um so now discussion on this
amendment in light of of
what other things have happened this
since
February sure um I think just for a
little bit of history and background on
House Bill 159 the intent here is to
come up with a strategy to allow um our
utilities to procure Energy Services
more than twice a year more than every
six months um very similar to when we
talk about in an Investment Portfolio
where you want to be able to have both
short and long-term Investments at
different levels of risk to then even
out a portfolio so even if the market is
not doing great your Investments should
still stay steady because you have a
good mix in a similar way we're looking
at coming up with a solution for
electricity so that we can have our
electric rates stay steady with a
investment mix of both short and
long-term cost procurement right now
what we're looking at is just a
six-month procurement timeline which
unfortunately we have seen and many of
our constituents have felt uh where we
had crazy leaps in cost for electricity
uh due to obviously some international
issues cost of natural gas uh volatility
in the Market but nonetheless that
really hurts our constituents because
they can't plan for especially
businesses but also U homeowners
everybody's pocketbook is hit you can't
plan for a long-term Financial impacts
if you don't know how things are going
to be and so rather than having these
jumps up and down and the volatility the
goal of House Bill 159 was to come up
with a strategy of laddering so that we
would have more consistent electric
rates and I want to say for the record
to be super clear the goal was not to
have cheaper necessarily the goal was to
have consistent reliable and something
that people can Budget on uh so
obviously the first version of House
Bill 159 did not go very well um and you
know it was a draft I would say we had
some discussions we got good feedback
from uh testimony from all of you uh and
then the response was to do the February
amendment to House Bill 159 which I
still think Falls a little bit short uh
but the goal once again was to come up
with something that could be more
consistent um I understand that the
department of energy was concerned about
additional cost for Staffing um and I
think that that's a valid concern uh
seeing as we are entering into a
non-budget year it's difficult to come
up with a Staffing Solution when we
can't allocate funds for that
nonetheless I still think that enabling
and allowing our utilities to go out to
bid more than once every six months
should for our constituents provide more
price stability so that's some
background on 159 um and I would say
that I don't believe that this February
amendment is really the answer but I
think it's better than the initial bill
um and I do believe that representative
Bernardi the chair of the sub commmittee
has come up with something even
better any other com any other
comments um just a clarification yeah
yeah
just a clarification um this amendment
that we're going to be talking about um
it talks about only Electric utilities
so were we not concerned about um the
natural gas and the other
utilities the bill that I proposed is
focused on El electrical
rates not not Gas
Utilities so natural gas is a part of
the cost of electricity in New Hampshire
because we're using natural gas to
produce electricity in many cases yeah
it is the driver of the cost that we see
okay Hydro nuclear Basel load so
anything that changes the electric rates
in New Hampshire is virtually entirely
uh derivative of natural gas prices okay
thank
you so um hearing that discussion and
your you know your
um comments about the inadequacy or or
well the falling a little short of the
desired goal uh as you mentioned I had
proposed a bill for the next session uh
which you have as an lsar I I sent to
you
folks
um which
specifically
uh is focused on
um on lading of of
contracts um I did get some comments
because uh I spoke with the Department
of energy during the summer to find out
what their preliminary thoughts on that
were they sent me an email that
commented both on uh HB 159 but the
bottom of that email was comments on on
the concept of lattering uh it
referenced uh a puci ir and and a um
Department of energy
IV uh and I provided those for you
um the bottom line is the Department of
energy is not yet ready to sign on to
the concept of lading I mean one of the
the words they use are uh uh lading
options offer net positive results in
periods when Energy prices sharply
increase and opposite occurs in stable
or decreasing energy price Market uh the
next comment is latter contracts are
longer term I think that's where there
may be a disconnect between uh the bill
that I proposed and some that we've
spoken about and where the doe is is
going here because I I'm viewing laded
contracts and and the uh the bill that
that uh um OS has prepared thus far
doesn't say this but I'm viewing the
contract period be from three months to
nine or 12 months and I'm open for some
discussion on that but
um a a period that is less than the
current six Monon uh required uh
Contracting period which puts us into
this position of buying at what may be a
peak and then living with that for six
months so a three to n or 3 to 12 Monon
um contract period uh that with then
potentially allow the utilities to
survey the market survey what's
happening in the industry uh and
purchase uh electric power at
potentially a more more stable rate now
there was a report uh by the p on the
8th of May where they went over th this
uh
uh circumstance they
reviewed uh eversource Unitil and uh
Liberties uh contracts and prices from
2018 through
2023 uh and
demonstrating uh the difficulty of the
six-month uh
required uh Contracting
to keep a stable or more stable uh
energy Market
um all right hopefully that's good
okay um H and then at the back they get
comments from some of the community and
other uh Power producers uh and they
have uh
share
share that with the rest of the
committee uh this is the uh Doe's report
um anyway at the back of the report see
pu's report uh they
discuss uh New Hampshire Electric
Cooperative um which uh is not regulated
by the Pu but did provide some
comments and they indicated that its
service was proc appeared largely
through a blend of short medium and
long-term
contracts uh with which then allowed
them to not suffer as high a price spike
as the other three major
utilities uh saw when they were on the
six-month contract uh period it also
includes a comment from the Department
of energy that
uh that they did not yet support uh a a
lading concept
um but
uh again that I believe their their
assessment is that these contracts would
all all be of a longer term
nature so I think there still is an
opportunity here for us to uh to move
forward with a a Ling uh uh proposal and
um I I'm uh moving forward with this LSR
and and I would be willing to accept
amendments from the doe or other folks
before this committee takes it up
formally in the uh in the next session
uh so if there are some uh interesting
ideas on that that are forthcoming uh
this committee would definitely be
willing to entertain
them uh furthermore the doe has a uh
investigation on this and and as
indicated in in their papers their
report on their position is going to be
coming out in
December uh so we should get better idea
of their thoughts in that
regard
um so with those comments I I guess uh
I'm does anybody else on the committee
have anything they would like to add yes
thank you chair um just a comment on the
department of Energy's review of
lettering I I would be interested to
hear from the Department as to where
they definition of lading is coming from
because we're certainly seeing shorter
term contracts in other states so I'd
just like some more feedback on
that
good morning my name is Tom France I'm
the director of regulatory at the
department of energy previous to this
position I held positions as Chief
Economist and director of electric at
the Public Utilities
Commission um as you mentioned we have a
ongoing investigation at the department
of energy that's uh sort of jumps off
from the pu's report we are deep into
that investigation at this point we have
a expert consulting firm we've met with
and discussed a number of these very
issues with the utilities and continue
to do so we will also be interviewing uh
our expectations will be interviewing
with thirdparty wholesale
suppliers uh number of other parties
we've even reached out and had a
productive interview just last week
concerning descending clock auctions
which some states use to procure default
service um I was at the Pu when we did
actually have laddering for some of our
utilities definitely makes rates
somewhat more stable
um is somewhat
attractive when rates are going up and
much less so when rates are going down
one should always keep in mind that we
live in a world in New Hampshire where
there is uh
third-party retail supply and customers
can and have and will continue to do so
when it's in their best interest to
switch from the utility default service
to thirdparty
supply um and that actually occurred
when the rates were going up under a
lading
situation uh I mean so so the lattering
was actually had rates tied in but as
the rates actually dropped in the
markets and the default Service uh
contracts reflected older long-term
contracts folks moved to default service
I mean to uh third party supply that was
actually more reflective of the market
and lower so my my comments on this is
we have the opportunity we have the
ability the Pu has the ability right now
to actually still have lading in there
um and certainly some states do
it it hides to some degree what the
actual costs are in the market depending
on how long those contracts uh are
extended with suppliers and at this
point I'd say let's wait and see what
our uh in-depth report looks like in in
December any initial Insight on the time
window of laddering that you're looking
at well most places have sort of a
shortterm midterm long-term long-term in
these markets is usually two to three
years most contracts and most suppliers
don't want to enter into uh contracts
for much longer than two or three years
and then they roll over so you're
rolling over some shortterm and then
every three years entering another
long-term term deal
markets can change as you know based on
world conditions rapidly and
significantly so what what's the
shortterm window that you those
short-term windows are still in the six-
month period still are not not less than
six months
uh they're you can maybe see three
months but suppliers in New England are
used to six-month
periods and there's a cost to going out
if you're going out every two or three
months for Supply there's a cost to the
to the wholesale suppliers to actually
put those bids together uh contract for
it so there's not a lot of contracts in
New England that are less than six
months but six months to 12 months is
very common uh sometimes you'll see a
little bit more than that and we'll
we'll be covering this in depth in in
our
report
members of the committee yes Mr Carman
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so it was it's
interesting you're saying that when um
prices are rising because of lading um
well not because of lading well okay I
me so actually so let's say let's say
prices are actually decreasing so the uh
the the alternative suppliers the
non-default suppliers the prices are
decreasing so customers are leaving
default service mhm is there an impact
on the utilities are they have they
overbought at that point are they
someone stuck with extra energy actually
that's a very good question because the
risk is on the and it's meant to be is
on the
third uh party supplier so so that's why
we moved to restructuring really and put
the generation Supply risk on third
party suppliers it's it's not on the
utility and we try to make sure that
it's not and the utility have the
utilities have very good representation
to make sure they're not because they're
not making any money on this this is a
pass through for them and so they go out
and they solicit they make sure that the
companies that they're are bidding on
this are uh financially capable and
managerially and administratively
capable to supply the the full
requirements of default service but the
risk if you think about a third party
supplier there's a risk for price they
can hedge some of that risk there's a
risk for quantity that one's actually a
little tougher to to to actually hedge
so they are obligated to
provide supply for all those customers
so if they're expecting let's say just
throughout a number
100 million megawatt
hours
but their prices are and end up being
higher than they should be or could be
compared to the market and other people
start undercutting those in the in the
retail supply Market in New
Hampshire that 100 uh that million
megawatt hours may actually end up being
too much that they actually expected to
supply and they'll be tied up with that
when people are leaving Because the
actual load will be less now they have
to do something with that so that's a
quantity risk and then of course if they
don't hedge well there's a price risk
and It ultimately those risks will be
reflect collected in their bid
prices so I I I guess I'm still a little
unclear so let's let's say that um
Liberty contracts for a total of 500
million megawatt hours for some period
but people are leaving default service
and actually the Liberty customers need
only half of that 250 million megawatt
hours is liberty and Liberty has a
contract for 500 million is Liberty then
on the hook for that remaining 250 where
who who's paying for that the supplier
is on the hook for that because it's
literally a all requirements contract so
if they expected 500,000 megawatt hours
and it's now half of that they have
somehow uh
provided through contract contracts with
with generators enough power to supply
that or from the market and so they now
have to do something with that
excess it's not on the utility it's not
on the customers it's on the wholesale
suppliers and they take those
risks um can I ask you I'm very
interested to learn more about the
thirdparty suppliers and the
participation rate in terms of um
quantify the number of people who are
either businesses or residential who
choose to go with a third party supplier
rather than default service yeah we have
a lot of that I'm happy to send that to
you but in general it is sort of what
you'd expect the large cni customers
historically have moved to retail supply
in New Hampshire and that's true in
other states too there sophisticated
saving an extra three four five Mills
per kilowatt hour potentially is a big
deal to them when they're purchasing
millions of kilowatt hours per month um
and so what we've seen pretty much
across the board is the large commercial
industrial customers in some cases over
80 to 90% have actually moved a retail
supply
um economically that makes sense the
value to them is much higher they have
uh more at
stake residential customers the cost of
searching the cost of energy the cost of
looking into
contracts is higher potentially for them
for what their savings might be might
only potentially be two three five6
dollar per month but that's seems like a
lot but there's a cost to that to
actually sign up beond the contract
monitor the contract know when the
contract ends uh what the prices are so
res residential
customers about somewhere around 15%
maybe 20 20% at most have actually moved
to competitive retail supply in New
Hampshire uh it depends a little bit by
the service territory it also depends a
little bit what time frame we're looking
at and
circumstances uh so and then if it
depends a little bit when they can leave
their leave their retail supplier some
leave and come back to default service
also if the default service price now is
lower uh and you have to be the retail
supply
you have to be somewhat careful what
happens at the end of the contract does
it move to a uh variable rate is it much
higher you know if it's like anything
you sign up for as a residential person
uh you have to you have to pay attention
yeah so as a followup um what I'm
hearing is that our residential
customers are not nearly as
sophisticated as our commercial
customers there's about a 15%
participation rate with the third party
suppliers although my understanding is
when we set up this system initially the
goal was that default service would not
really be the service that residential
customers were using but in effect
what's happened is it is what that
percentage of customers so what are we
at 85% of residential customers that
aren't
doing third-party contracts are just
going with default because it's all they
know they're not sophisticated they
don't know how to sign up they don't
know how to research they don't know how
to get a better deal and there's some
fear I've heard from my constituents
there's some fear that there will be a
balloon payment or some additional cost
or they'll be stuck with a variable rate
after the term ends so just like when
you're doing an introductory rate to a
credit card you have to be very careful
to get out of it before it goes to a
much higher rate it's the same thing
with electric so you're playing a bit of
a game there's a sophistication level
required or you end up getting burned
and certainly I would say in New
Hampshire those 85% of the customers are
the folks who are residential customers
I'm not talking about commercial here I
think they're the ones who are looking
to us to come up with a way to protect
them because they're going to continue
using the default service rate however
if you in your experience have some
ideas for how we could incentivize
better deals or more education on the
residential customer side so that we can
fix what was intended to be a system
that allowed people to not use default
service I'm very interested in
suggestions because I think we're stuck
now with 85% residential in default
service which isn't doing anyone any
favors we will be addressing that in our
report that that is really one of the
reasons we're doing the Deep dive in
there are no easy solutions here uh we
have I think a excellent cons uh
consumer group at the department of
energy and there's a fair amount of of
very good information on our website
about uh retail suppliers prices what's
out there uh but those are search costs
I mean I'm an economist and there's
definitely a search cost to looking at
that and understanding that and and
going through a contract and wondering
well how much am I really going to save
what period is it what happens at the
end of the contract we recognize that
that that's uh that's true in the energy
Market markets and as many other markets
as as you
mentioned yeah I I would just like to
add to to that I I think the uh the
constituents that I've spoken to by and
large have no clue that they can look
for other sources of you electrical
supply and when they're told they can
I've had people come back to me and say
I still don't know how to do it it you
know uh so the the process and how to do
it and and what the ramifications of it
are uh that has to be made much more
clear to folks people have said uh well
I put some solar panels on and now uh
will I lose the value of that if I
change my service it doesn't say
anything about that in the uh in all the
you information that I looked at so uh
it's it remains a huge problem it's one
of the biggest issues that that I run
into when I talk to constituents go to
public meetings what's going on with
electrical prices and how can we get
greater stability and and ideally
reduction in their cost um so to the
extent that you folks are working on a
December date I would highly advise as
my compatriot here has said you need to
focus in on on that issue uh as well as
you know what options are there to uh
bringing the costs closer to what the
market costs are on a on a realtime
basis when CH
yes thank you um so it's been mentioned
that um during this six-month period um
without the lading that that utilities
could buy high but then the prices might
fall right and you're stuck with that
high price for six months my question is
what happens to that extra money is it
refunded to it clearly is not refunded
to the customers but is it just pure
profit for the utilities no the
utilities make no money on this so if
I'm a utility let's say eversource and I
enter into after I go out for
solicitation I issue a request for bids
uh I
get X number of bids come in I evaluate
the bids on a lowest cost basis for the
average price for the next six months
now the price will vary based on the
month months
like uh December and January are
obviously higher price months in in this
region than than something like
September and October and that has to do
with the price of natural gas but that
contract then is uh signed if everything
goes well
it's the case is filed at the Public
Utilities Commission the OCA Department
of energy copies of it it's a really
fast docket because that uncertainty
about getting the contract approved is
another risk to a re to a wholesale
supplier to and if approved then the
contracts executed and the prices become
effective a couple months later on the
first of the month in this case for most
for our utilities it's February 1 for
six months um
and the price that let's say residential
customers pay is an average price for
each of those for all six months perhaps
it's well 20 cents to during the winter
period when a lot of winter months are
involved uh and right now ever sources
price is more like 11 and half to 12
cents so at the end of that six months
well let's get back to your question so
uh the
supplier hopes that they hedge their
fuel risk that they got the quantities
right that everything was bid correctly
and they cover all their costs and make
a little bit bit of money for
sure
followup so um you just described um the
procedure for um getting to this
contract you go out and you evaluate the
bids and everything I assume this has
been the same procedure for eons this is
what people do right just slightly less
than eons right right but I I think my
point is it's 2023 shouldn't things have
gotten a little easier a little faster
to especially with the internet to to
look at the information that's out there
I guess my question is why hasn't this
procedure evolved well I think it's
adjusted somewhat I mean uh it's adjust
based on the market conditions the
suppliers uh what the risks are but we
spend a fair amount of time looking at
other states and other places some
states do it a little bit differently
for example parts of Pennsylvania and
Ohio use a descending clock auction we
we're looking at that um because it may
actually get slightly better prices or
has some advantages but in general for
the states that have restructured now
again this is for states that have
restructured and and divested their
generating assets or their long-term
purchase power contracts others many
many states in in our country still are
vertically integrated and have uh
generation assets or long-term purchase
power contracts are both and so that's
basically a cost of service as we did it
forever up till n up till about 2000
2001 but for the last 20 years this is a
pretty standard way the the the time
frames have become a little bit quicker
the risks are tried to be reduced to the
suppliers to get a little bit better
pricing um but this is pretty standard
and I think we're always asking I know
the utility
uh purchases are also saying well how
can we do this better what can make it
more efficient what can reduce the risk
a little bit better so I think we always
ask that question and try to look at
it and that's one of the things we're
looking at uh with our consultant and
and hope to address in the report but
this is a pretty standard procedure for
Most states that actually are divested
thank
you
thank thank you Mr chairman thank you
again Mr France uh one thing we haven't
discussed is community power which is on
the rise I live in Lebanon and in fact
we have Community power there and we're
going to see Community power in more and
more communities uh I'm wondering if you
can speak about the effects that uh
customers moving onto Community power
will have on default service and in
particular I wonder about uh this isn't
really about the the uh contracts but I
think about the auctions where if the
demand for default service
decreases it seems like the clearing
prices also ought to decrease so I'm
wondering if you can speak to community
power yeah I'm not going to spend a lot
of time on that at this point but I will
say this about Community power it offers
uh opportunities for savings for
potential potentially for savings for
communities um it is
and I have talked to many
suppliers uh and we hear this and we
hear it from our utility purchasers with
with the wholesale suppliers it is a
risk that they are aware of and to some
degree still coming to grips with how it
affects their bids for default service
some of it's
just timing some of it's understanding
uh when folks go to community power so
that the wholesale suppliers can
actually hedge that understand if that
load leaves how large that load is but
if you're expecting potentially to sell
a million megawatt hours and you have a
number of communities large ones leaving
during a certain period uh if they know
that they can maybe hedge that pretty
pretty well but they have concerns about
it and it is definitely an area we will
be addressing in our
report then that's all I'd really like
to say about it for right for right
now but everybody well having said that
I'll say one more thing everybody's in
plays in the same same Market you know
whether you're Community power uh group
out there
purchasing in the market or or your a
utility uh negotiating contract with a
wholesale
supplier uh there one big Market in New
England all those folks are buying power
for default service or to retail supply
or for Community power and that's the
same basic generation across New England
and the same
players more comment if you could in
indulge me Mr fron um I'm just reviewing
this report on New Hampshire energy
commodity procurement I don't know if
you're familiar with this or not I'm
just looking at it for the first time P
um it's from the Pu and it looks like it
was published May 8 this year PU Report
okay so on page eight um there's a
comment from
Unitil uh where apparently they they had
an issue in Massachusetts where one of
their subsidiaries went out to do a an
RFP solicitation and it failed MH and so
Unitil made the comment that um the New
Hampshire puc should authorize Electric
utilities to self-supply Via direct
purchases from the iso New England
Market in the event of a failed
solicitation without further
administrative or regulatory process
beyond what is currently undertaken for
approval of default Service rates with
the standardized approach to retail
ratemaking what are your thoughts on
that because I think that that's kind of
interesting if there's a failed
well honestly there aren't many choices
if there's a failed auction
unfortunately and and we've had certain
tranches of power for certain customer
classes over certain periods even in New
Hampshire fail recently and that was a
self-supply issue ultimately the policy
right now is that you quickly turn it
around go back out hope that uh someone
realized they maybe should have actually
bid on
that power and and maybe we'll submit a
bid but if they
don't uh the time frames are tight uh
and ultimately I think we end up with a
self-supply issue self-supply is
interesting because it'll truly reflect
the market price but it also puts
tremendous risk on customers because
instead of knowing what that price is
now you're at the whims of a market that
can vary dramatically hourly daily
monthly and that'll that price will
ultimately get Tred up over time
so
uh we're looking at it in the report
it's one of the aspects that we we're
diving into
um and we'll be addressing it there I'm
not sure I want
to go a whole lot further than that at
this point thank you I appreciate you
looking into it in the report it seems
like it would be way better for our
constituents than the volatility of the
the ongoing rate changes well remember
that self-supply is perhaps the most
volle of all supp all pricing again
depending it could be though that you
set the price and customers then adjust
to the real type real prices in the
market and for whatever reason the
actual price goes down and customers
will may maybe actually save on on
self-supply uh it's a complicated issue
but there's definitely risks ass
associated with self-supply
too thank you very much my
pleasure thank you Mr France uh we look
forward to the uh December
report uh Mr Lata or any of the other uh
utilities have any comments they would
like to
make
thank you uh Michael Lata representing
eversource um really great discussion
this morning and I think the uh
subcommittee is really focusing in on a
number of the the key issues um that you
want to consider when looking at at
default service and um I just put a fine
point on a couple of them uh that were
mentioned one is
um as the legislature looks at default
service I think defining what the role
as we sit here in in
2023 of default service is um so RSA
374f uh colon 3 sort of provides the
framework that the utilities and the
commission and now doe Implement default
service which is kind of the the basic
parameters and it's it's actually very
high level level um just that default
service should be a safety net for
customers uh assure universal access and
be procured through um the competitive
market and
so the discussion uh started off that
you know perhaps we want default service
to be a more stable product um and and
that's certainly you know the purview of
the legislature to direct the utilities
and the the commission to develop a
framework around a a more stable product
lading is one way to to reduce
volatility and Achieve that end um
previously you know I I think the
commission uh had looked at it as more
of a a market-based uh approach um so
you want the prices to be as reflective
of the wholesale Market um so customers
experience the the changes in the market
so those are just two different um
different obviously approaches and
uh given the the volatility that we've
seen um you know certainly makes sense
that the commission and might excuse me
the legislature might want to revisit
that uh
and Tom talked a lot about the report
and I know they're looking at a number
of of these issues as well um another
consideration is um how detailed uh you
would want legislation to be um you know
one approach is you you sort of set a
goal you know price stability reduce
volatility or you know more reflective
of of markets and then you direct uh the
commission to develop a
framework um to achieve that goal
another approach is you sort of put that
framework into statute which um you know
you'll probably get closer to what you
want if it's in uh in statute but if you
need to make changes and adjust that
then obviously you have to go back and
change the law uh as opposed to some
some additional flexibility that the uh
regul regulator may have if you're just
setting a policy goal um and the the
final piece or actually there's one
other item I just want to touch on uh
but uh you know as Tom described this is
a pass through um this is basically
we're procuring this service on behalf
of our customers what we pay in the
market every six months is um what the
customers pay we do not profit um and
you know one of the areas as you're
looking at this um that the utilities
would have a concern or I should really
just say eversource but I I think the
other utilities would share it is is the
amount of risk the utility is taking on
so the more flexibility and sort of
utility judgment you put into the
process the more risk you're potentially
putting on the utility so if you said
hey utility go out you know and by three
months six months one year you decide
your port folio and and get the best
deal for customers you know one of the
concerns that utility would have is
these are very volatile markets and what
if we're wrong right what if we think
we're we're doing the right thing at the
period of time and we use our best
judgment but it turns out that prices
went down uh and then there's concern
that you know someone could look back
and say oh you know your your choices
resulted in um customers paying higher
costs
and should there be a disallowance and
that's not a position we want to be in
that's not a risk that we want to take
as part of this process so um having a
clearly defined process you know one of
the benefits of the current process is
every six months you shall do X and you
know we move on uh but having a clearly
defined process that doesn't put
additional risk on the utility again as
a pass through product uh is is
important um um and the final thing I
just want to say is is just touching on
um representative MC Williams last
question of uh of Tom um in terms of
self-supply this was a a serious concern
that eversource um had going into uh
last winter that we would have um really
a failed solicitation so no one would we
put out our our load following RFP and
no one would bid in um or the bids that
we would get would be so outside of what
we would expect them to be that it would
our view be a failed auction and so um
just to put sort of a fine point on what
self Supply is or what we were
considering at the time and what other
Utilities in fact we did have a failed
uh RFP for our large customer group but
as Tom mentioned they're largely already
being served by competitive suppliers um
we would simply go to to the iso Market
and procure uh the day ahead price so if
you look at your your ISO app there's a
real time and a day ahead so you know
again we wouldn't be sort of using
judgment uh there we we don't have power
plants to supply with uh we would just
take the the day ahead pricing and
that's what our our customers would pay
and um as as noted that would be you
know that's probably the most volatile
of all the options so uh just want to
put a a a fine point on that and then um
and to representative uh uh Wendy
Thomas's question about you know hey why
don't you do this differently um a
couple of things I point out eversource
actually divested of our uh generation
assets um and started this current
process I think it was
2018 uh so we've been doing this
six-month RFP not for a terribly long
time um and uh we do look as as Tom said
at ways to improve this and um just to
give an example one of the things we did
last year because of this concern about
failed auctions was uh while at the
six-month period we're going out for our
full customer load we actually broke
that up into to smaller tranches so
suppliers didn't have to bid on
everything so we're going out for
everything but they could bid in on on
smaller pieces and we we did find that
that attracted or we believe that
attracted larger number of suppliers so
uh so we do look to to improve the
process within the existing framework uh
as we go uh but certainly you know there
there is risk of uh of failure due to
the
volatility thank you Mr chairman thank
you Mr L always good to see
you I'm I'm thinking about uh what you
said about the utilities being um let's
say locked into uh situations where it's
not optimal you know they get locked
into something and I'm thinking about s
sp54 which allows for up to 20y year
contracts for up to 20% of the load and
I'm wondering how eversource views that
do you think eversource will be availing
themselves of such contracts and and
what about the risk profile there sure
uh one of the things that the
legislature did um to address that risk
issue in Senate Bill 54 was um the
utility essentially is acting as a for
lack of a better word of putting it
almost like a financing agent for uh the
generation asset so we put out a a
competitive RFP um you know different
generators would would bid into that
based on the criteria we would make a
selection and then um under Senate Bill
54 we would purchase that power at a
fixed price and resell it into the
marketplace uh and if there are uh the
idea would be that that power is less
expensive than the market and um
customers would receive the benefit of
that however if the cost of the fixed
price contract uh exceeded the market
price then that would be uh essentially
collected from customers as a a truing
up over a period of time so uh so there
was sort of a mechanism built into uh
that statute to to address that risk so
that the utility would be sort of
comfortable to proceed in that process
and not expose itself uh to
risk
so you started off saying one of your
concerns with potential lading was
uh you might be subject to the risk of
having made bad judgments in choice of
contracts uh and uh locked yourself into
some uh contracts where the price was
higher than the the market and
um I guess I'm I have a little
difficulty understanding that because
right now you you are doing contracts at
six Monon intervals and you if when you
do that you know if the market price
drops
two months in and stays low for the last
last four months uh customers are are
paying that elevated price you aren't
paying any uh anything for as a penalty
for that
so how how would it be different if we
just said you could have contracts that
range from three to 15 months sure it um
it's a fair question it depends on on
the structure of the lading so if you
were to um say utility go out you
know twice a year for 50% of your load
for one-year contract so you're breaking
up the load so it's not 100% every six
months but it's 50% every every six
months but their year-long contract so
you're staggering it great like we know
what to do and we would Implement that
uh that's actually similar to what we do
in in other states but if you were to
say uh utility you may procure three
months six months one year use your best
judgment and you know make your filings
for approval at the commission so give
us lots of of um
flexibility that would be I think a
concern for for the utility to have sort
of too much judgment in it um so the
concept of lading itself we very
comfortable with um and have experience
with it's just how prescriptive is it um
you know you could say you know three
months uh excuse me three procurements
per year at
varying um uh intervals uh but as long
as that's clear and we're implementing
that either regulation or statute we
don't have an issue with that it would
be if you said hey you know use your
best judgment to get the best
deal that in you know would uh uh
increase the risk for the utility to to
sort of you
know be making that judgment um uh
within a framework versus executing a
framework if that makes sense so so you
would be at risk of the slings and
arrows of public perception for having
made bad uh decisions but I I the cost
still should be the same irrespective of
you know to the customer or to you
because it's all passed through you just
made some bad judgments that your
customers are going to be impacted by
sure we we don't want to be in the
position
where we may make bad judgments I I
guess uh we quite frankly don't have um
those staff members anymore uh you know
back when we own generation we were
managing our portfolio dispatching
generation making market market purchase
is when we uh divested of generation we
you know those people either do other
things or have retired or or left the
company and so um you know I guess what
I'm uh saying is you know we we want a
clear framework that we're executing as
opposed to to
managing thank
you Mr
Corman um so we heard earlier that it it
sounds like it is possible to Lad
already that it's not prohibited uh is
there a reason that eversource has not
laded so far in New Hampshire and if we
actually had legislation that actually
exp explicitly says you may lad would
that
somehow enable you to Lad more than you
are able to
now
um so the reason that eversource does
not uh uh ladder in New Hampshire is
because of commission order following uh
electric restructuring and the sale of
Our Generation assets the company
actually uh we had to propose how we
would procure energy on behalf of our
customers and the company's proposal um
at the time I think this was in the 2017
time frame was actually to to do lading
um and the commission um directed us as
part of a settlement we we agreed to it
um to do the current six-month month
block so um so if the legislature were
to um direct either the utility or
obviously the commission to approve
lading we would certainly Implement that
and I I suppose it would provide a level
of of clarity on what the legislature
wants from a procurement standpoint but
um we did propose that uh uh and as as
um Mr France had mentioned other
utilities uh had previously employed
that procurement
strategy so to follow up on that what
I'm hearing is this it sounds like from
ever source's perspective you would like
more Direction you want sort of an
engineered setup structure where the
legislation says there's a certain
number of procurements per year at a
certain interval for a certain period of
time and you want to be told that's what
you're going to do rather than what my
colleague had suggested which was
enabling legislation that says the
utilities may do between three and say
18mth period bids because you want more
Direction you don't want it to be loose
you don't want an artistic solution you
want an engineered solution is that what
I'm hearing about eversource's approach
here sure if the
legislature
um wants to change uh how the utilities
procur default service
um we would want clear Direction either
through statute or direction from the
regulator so an approach as I said you
know you could say in the legislation it
says you will do X or
alternatively um you could could direct
the Public Utilities Commission to
develop that framework based upon your
public policy objectives or you could
direct the utilities to um uh propose a
framework for approval by the Pu but we
want a clear consistent framework um
whether that comes from the legislature
directly or comes from uh the commission
and you know there's probably a bit more
uh flexibility in the regulatory
approach uh because you don't have to
change the law every time you want to
change this process but but we would
want sort of clear Direction coming out
of
whatever uh body is is making the the
changes thank
you oh thank you chair thank you Mr Lata
um many of my concerns are just answered
so just a refresh FR right now the
utilities would have to with this
amendment proposed the utilities be
working with the PCU Department of
energy and the commiss the commission
now to come up with a way would that not
clarify for the utilities what to
do with Through The Regulators with this
amendment are you
thinking we should look into different
wording thank you I I I'm not sure which
amendment you're referring to I I did
have representative MC Williams
Amendment from February if it's a
different amendment I I have not seen
that so I I I think what he's referring
to is is there is a LSR that is
proposing lading it has not been fully
drafted by the uh uh OS uh and but
that's the concept that that we have
been talking about as as derivative of
HB 159 discussion here got I I've seen
the LSR title outside of that I guess I
can't speak to the you know I thank it
my apologies to that I was refering to
LSR I think that is going to be
addressed um do look it up and get back
to
us we'd be happy to to weigh in on on
language as it gets developed uh
um thank you Mr chairman yeah one other
question I'm just thinking uh right now
you're in this mode where every six
months you go out for a contract and
let's suppose that with lading it's
every three months or every two months
so you're going out for contracts more
frequently does that add an
administrative cost that that is
increased because of that increased
frequency of going after contracts is
that an added administrative cost and
then does that if so does that get
passed through to
customers the answer to both questions
is yes the the the more uh rfps we we uh
put out into the market and then review
the results uh that is added cost and
then the filings associated with those
for approval at the commission and I
think uh Mr France had mentioned also
the uh cost of the suppliers to respond
to those ultimately that is pass through
to customers
yes thank you Mr chair um first of all I
I want you to know that I give respect
to anyone who uses the phrase slings and
[Music]
arrows um my my my question is that um
you're clearly asking for an for what uh
representative MC Williams said an
engineered
solution um and so you're asking the
legislature to to essentially tell you
guys what to do um my concern is what if
we don't get it right what if we don't
include something and so what I'm saying
I guess is
that I I mean I agree with this this LSR
um I do have some questions on it um but
isn't that your job to sort of tell us
the procedures so that we can then
incorporate it instead of us telling you
what to do sure and I apologize if if
um I wasn't uh sort of
clear if the legislature wants to change
how default service is is procured there
there's two ways to go about doing that
um one is to put the process that you
want into statute and we would be H if
that is the direction you decide to go
in um we would be happy to work with the
legislature and offer suggestions based
upon our experience in other states um
the concern representative Thomas that
you're raising a what if we get that
wrong despite everybody's best
intentions um the other way to go about
doing it is to put public policy
objectives into statute and say we want
default service to reflect you know
reduced volatility on behalf of
customers and be procured you know
through a competitive process so and you
direct the
regulator um to approve that type or
develop uh that type of of solicitation
so that way you're saying these are the
goals that the legislature wants and
Public Utilities
Commission Implement that and obviously
the utilities would would implement M
through our filing so
um what I'm the concern that I'm just
raising um is if you were to say you
know sort of open the doors for the
utility and say hey utility go out and
get the best deal for for the customer
you can do three months you can do six
months you can do it whenever you want
your
monitoring that increases risk because
um there a lot of judgment there's a lot
of volatility and uh that would open the
door for for sort of second guessing and
and the threat of disallowance if if we
were incorrect
followup thank you um so if we put this
into public policy
objectives um how would you recommend
that those objectives be measured
because you cannot have objectives that
are not
measurable so you would uh
uh if you were to change the RSA to say
that the purpose of default service is
to provide a a safety net and shall um
be procured in a manner to reduce price
volatility
um then it would be on the utilities and
commission well really the commission to
approve um
uh filings that reflected that and so
lading would be one instrument that you
could use um to reduce volatility uh and
so uh you know there's a lot of review
that goes into these these filings um
and you know there are periodic uh
investigations uh there were two that Mr
France had mentioned one by the
commission one by by the doe and so so
you know as you gain
experience you know you can go back and
look and say did this work out how we
intended it and one of the benefits of
uh if you were pursuing more of a
regulatory solution versus having a
structure in statute is the regulator
could make make changes to that um you
know if they found that It produced bad
outcomes they could could make uh you
know direct the utilities to make
changes in their next
filing thank you very
much I'm going to ask since this is a
working session there's nothing formal
here is there anybody else in the
audience that is interested in making
comments on the the concepts that we've
been discussing
here all right hearing none um what this
Comm committee needs to do is first well
it needs to do I guess two things we've
talked about here at the same time one
is address what are we going to do with
the current HB
159 as a as the Amendments been proposed
uh and then
um any any further Insight or
recommendations on the LSR that is in
preparation still so uh I'm going to
first start we have a motion on the
table seconded that we uh adopt the uh
uh amendment to HB
159 I think our initial discussion was
none of us thought it was ready for
prime time but we need to vote on that
and and then move to the next step so uh
I don't have a clerk so I'm going to
just call the rooll myself Wendy Thomas
um well
I um I guess I'm going to vote no on on
that Amendment based on on the
discussions that we've
had Williams um I have a further
Amendment but I'm gonna vote no on this
one for a different Amendment all right
so no and and the chair votes no so the
amendment as uh February Amendment the
February Amendment uh
fails oh is he subbing for some
reason yeah
yeah you're
advising okay so you have a further
amendment I do um so my proposal is we
take your your draft LSR and we put it
in as an amendment to 159 to continue
the
conversation um and obviously we could
have a floor amendment to it based on
the December study but to keep this
moving forward um I think I'd like to
try to keep it alive and put your we'll
call it the Bernardi
amendment to to
159 so I mean the LSR is going to go
forward anyway do we need to continue HB
159 or can we just rely on a new bill
number um I think it's a timing question
yeah right because if we can get good
input in the December review from the
Department of energy I think it would
really become a floor Amendment with
whatever the feedback we received for
the January vote but this just keeps it
alive so we keep talking about it and it
is likely not going to move forward much
past January but it's an ongoing
discussion we have a vehicle to keep
discussing until the LSR comes up for
hearing in January February right it's
just to keep it alive that's the
proposal all right um so I moved to
adopt the uh Bernardi LSR as an
amendment to House Bill
159 is there a second to that
motion yes there is but I have some
questions on it yes but yes this the
motion is to second that
right discussion
then
um it's it's sort of a a definition uh
on line 16 and and I want to make it
known I'm a writer I'm not an editor but
I do think that somebody went crazy with
the commas um on this line but it says
that the commission may Implement
measures to discourage misuse or
long-term use of default service can you
just Define
misuse oh
that is in the current statute the
my Amendment going to uh so wait a
minute here get the right you're you're
looking at
uh HP
yes6 yes so that's that's that's in the
current statute uh uh that has not been
changed by my Amendment or the February
amendment to HB
um I I can only speculate as we all can
as to what that means but it's not
Define you're
right so just a those commas are
currently in law yes okay thank
you all right any further
comment um just to follow up on intent
here um I'd like to keep House Bill 159
alive because I'd like it to be a
vehicle to receive information from the
report from the Department of energy in
December um and potentially have some
more discussion on this in January as a
full house which I don't have high hopes
for this actually passing but I see this
as sort of doing our homework and
getting our ducks in a row for the real
bill this LSR will become for hearings
next
spring all right El call a roll mayy
Thomas what are we voting on oh sorry on
adopting the LSR as an amendment to HB
as a replacement for HB
159 um in order to keep
hb9 alive yeah no I'm all for that thank
you yes Williams
chair votes I so we have done
so is any other
business people want to
raise all right uh with that I will
adjourn this working session of the
Science Tech and energy thank you very
much for your participation and we do
look forward to that December report
yeah
welcome everyone um I see we're past
1:00 so time we would get going um this
is a uh work session uh of the St
committee for uh HB
558 um to my uh well the four voting
members of the subcommittee are myself
representative Doug Thomas
representative Wendy Thomas
representative Tom PL and representative
of C
McGee um uh we have four assigned to the
subcommittee it is my intent to go over
I understand there is a Amendment that's
been presented by representative Ammon
uh it's my intent to to uh bring him up
and discuss the amendment and then we
can discuss the pros and cons anybody
else that would like to come up and
speak on that Amendment or make other
alternative alternative um position May
and it is my intent that um we aren't
here that long but we'll be here as long
as it takes for people to discuss
matters and then we'll vote on the um on
our uh you recommended action uh in the
event that we get bogged down I have a
reserve today in case we have to meet
again but I don't believe we uh we will
need that I I I hope we don't so with
that in mind uh representative Ammon
please please come come on
down all right thank you for the record
my name is Keith Ammon I represent
Hillsboro District
42 um so we had the hearing the public
hearing on the original version of the
bill back in February I
believe and we had uh a lot of
testimony uh in support of the bill but
saying that it needed work and so over
the summer and in the most recent I'd
say six weeks is when it got more
intense I reached out to the different
parties that had testified uh including
the department of energy uh eversource
and clean energy New Hampshire those are
the three main stakeholders that that
gave input and I went through their
testimony and kind of compiled all the
concerns and began asking uh for a
solution uh to making the bill something
that could be passed and so we we
settled
on um this directive for the Department
of energy to conduct a technical study
of the issues surrounding micro
GDs um and if you look at the effective
date it's it's effective 60 days after
passage so that would be sometime maybe
April or May next year you know if it
goes through um and then 120 days from
that date or sorry 60 days from that
date begins this 120-day clock for the
Department of energy to prepare for the
study and then from that date so that
would put us
in July maybe November next year would
be the beginning of that year-long study
process and then they would be uh
requested to issue a final report that
covers the um the items listed in
section two and that section Roman
numeral 2 uh is pretty much a
compilation of the things that were
discussed in February during the public
hearing uh including one that I hadn't
thought of cyber security and phys
physical security and I think that was
an important one that didn't make it
into the original version of the
bill so and I think there's others here
in support if you would would uh have a
reason to call them up Mr
chairman
thank you representative questions from
our
subcommittee representative
mcge thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
for taking my question representative um
I took a look at this and I think it you
know what it has included in it looks
fine to me um I'm wondering if uh you
could speak a little bit about the
objective um are we looking to just get
additional information
over a year from now on micro grids um
so that we have more information or are
we looking to um bring about a pilot in
in other words I'm just trying to figure
out yeah what the objective is yeah
because because it's going to take us a
long time into the future and we did
have a micro grid study and an attempt
over UNH um which you probably know all
about right um that just sort of got
stalled and and didn't get implemented
so I'm just wondering how this is
intended to help sure if you look at the
very last line on the first page 32 it
says the report shall provide
guidance um to to the legislature and
the Public Utilities Commission on
developing a microgrid pilot program
that balances several different issues
um so eversource has had a recent
experience in Massachusetts with a a
micro grid
installation where they would have had
to install very expensive transmission
lines to solve an issue in a certain
community and instead they created a
micro grid that had some battery storage
that was able to uh negate the need for
that expensive transmission so um I
think ever Source has had a positive
experience in other states around this
concept of a micro grid um and I think
New Hampshire sort of needs to catch up
um I'll give you a little background on
the the impetus of this
bill um the governor signed an executive
order in 201 early
2022 created a a cryptocurrency and
digital asset commission okay and so we
had a year-long um commission it was
held at the Department of Business and
economic Affairs and we had various
experts come in and talk to um talk to
us about these issues and one of the
issu one of the the subjects that came
up was the subject of energy use so we
had all these energy experts come in and
talk to us about the energy use and it
turns out that there are scenarios where
um this this uh ability to vary the
load uh within a few minutes right so
you can ramp up and ramp down a mining
uh rig it's actually having positive uh
effects on encouraging overbuilding
capacity because it makes it makes a
project economically viable to be able
to utilize electricity that otherwise
wouldn't go to the grid you see what I'm
saying so that's that's the concept of a
large flexible load it could be hydrogen
production it could be a data center
like a data center that supports AI for
instance right there's there's these
ideas of large flexible loads that fit
kind of into this micro grid concept
where that extra piece could make the
whole project more economically viable
so that was the impetus of it we wanted
to make something technology
neutral um and that was the original
version of the bill was technology
neutral um also we have this commission
I think cat yo representative McGee youo
uh on small modular reactors and some of
these business
models are based on energy as a service
where the company will own maybe a 20
megawatt micro reactor and sell the
energy
um but do so within like the concept of
like an industrial power zone or
industrial park where you have large you
know manufacturers or data centers or
whatever it is who want to contract for
that energy so this would enable offers
yeah off-takers right so this would
enable lots of different scenarios it
would enable experimentation that
doesn't affect the larger grid and in
fact one of the requirements in the
amend mment is to study the effect on
resiliency of the rest of the git
because we know I think you you guys
heard from
um uh the author of shorting the
grid and she talked a lot about
resiliency or or you know that you want
to have your grid maintain capacity at
all times and so that idea of grid
resiliency is a big part of this study
so I'll stop talking there
but
the only other thing that that brings to
mind is the idea of whether or not there
needs to be we you know this talk here
about U interconnection with the main
power grid um system reliability and
operational impacts cost allocation
coordination with utilities I'm
wondering whether or not there should be
whether there needs to be a directive to
interact with the iso New England in
terms of um their experience with micro
grids that have already been set up in
other plac places in the region and I I
know that eversource has some you know
has some there are several people
probably in state that have experience
already with microG grids but I I guess
the point I would make is micr grids can
serve different purposes but we we would
have to Define upfront I think uh
through this study what kind of purposes
New Hampshire would like them to serve
right and then then you'd also have to
decide where and I think those kind of
discussions come from leaders ship so
I'm not sure I feel like the way that
the bill is written it's going to be
sort of a pingpong for a while in terms
of decision Mak you're speaking to me
and I thought it was a representative
Thomas I couldn't tell I'm sorry I I I
thought he said followup yeah I'm sorry
okay yeah I I just clicked that you it
wasn't represent I was looking at
you go ahead I'm sorry yeah I I thank
you representative Thomas for giving me
the floor um yeah so I
I guess we do this a lot right we have
bills where we're kind of fishing we're
saying you guys go find this out for us
so we have more information to make a
better decision or to figure out which
way we want to go but I'm wondering
whether the the language in the bill
also needs to include um more than just
the illusions on some of these things
but to sort of direct uh the department
of energy toward what it is we're trying
to get out of micro grids right you you
mentioned a couple of things that you
can get with micr grids
but I guess what is New Hampshire's
interest in having micro grids is it to
allow people to have energy that is
Standalone so that they do not have to
interact with the Grid or is it uh to be
able to act as an asset that can
interact with the Grid in times when
Peak demand is you know requiring that
we put more energy
on yeah no I hear what you're saying
um the uh it's my understanding that if
you wanted to build your own micro grid
if you had your own plot of land and you
could contract with other entities that
that's already allowed um so this would
be the point of the
interconnection is really the critical
thing and I think the department of
energy has already done uh a study
similar to this on interconnection
process so that you know they're it's a
technically challenging subject and you
need experts to um this is why we didn't
create like a like a legislative
commission um but we want to have you
know
experts uh who understand these issues
design it and I understand what you're
saying that we want to direct them so a
couple of things in the
bill if you look at line 26 on the first
page the role of microG grids would be
the focus would be uh economic growth
clean energy
Innovation and reliable electricity
service I think those three things are
uh you know key and and most of us could
agree that they're important so if if
you think there's a need to expand on
that further I'd be open to you know
suggestions or whatever the the
subcommittee wants to
do representative Winnie Thomas thank
you Mr chair um it's me
talking um sort of to piggyback on uh
representative um McGee's question um do
you see these micro grids eventually
leaving the regional grid is that the
purpose of all this uh it was leaving no
I think it's in it's the other way
around um that they would be built out
and then connected to the larger grid
and okay and there's there will be
requirements for that interconnection
and one of those will be that they have
to provide additional resiliency to the
larger grid um they can't make the make
our larger grid less stable it has to be
more stable so follow
up thank you um so so this in essence
building these microG grid I'm just
trying to understand this um it's it's
to provide services for outlying
communities or or stuff like that they
don't have this cap capacity right now
yeah so I mean it's hard to completely
imagine what the market might come up
with but one thing that I that comes to
mind in in my imag ination is this idea
of an industrial power zone so let's say
we have the Burgess power plant up in
you know there there's need for power
and jobs up in the North Country um and
our electricity is is expensive it's
prohibitive to manufacturing coming into
the state but if they could build a a a
you know industrial park that had its
own generation it could be wind and
solar and a battery uh Source right um
that was self- sustaining uh and then if
they wanted to have the additional
because there it's a two-way street
right if your grid connects to the
larger grid you get the benefit of when
you need power you can pull from the
larger grid um but it also should be
required to provide additional
resiliency the other way um and so you
know it's it would be beneficial for the
larger uh you know region and
state um so in your explanation you keep
talking about one company might have the
capacity to do this so and I I see that
in line 16 on page one it's the purpose
of this commission to come up with
definitions uh requirement definitions
and requirements yeah yeah so um so a
micro GD grid could be one or more is
that correct one or more customers for L
of right it could be a it could be a a
housing you know Community or it could
[Music]
be yeah right all right thank you so
this is for the Department to kind of
work out the details you know we heard
back in February that this is a complex
issue um but there's you know there's
interest in moving the ball forward in
this area but this would be a
recommendations from the Department of
energy and then it's up to the legisl at
that point to to act on those
recommendations
so uh I think I'll have a question here
um
so and I think this question was
probably going to be asked again again
for Department of energy
but we have been talking about micr
grids for several years now and we've
been talking about studies for several
years and I'm all for having this study
um legislation really moves slow is
there a way that we can
accelerate um the beginnings of this I
mean we have 60 days after enactment
which um I'm not sure why we did 60 days
and then 60 days for Preparation which
uh possibly can be explained by by Doe
is there any other way that we can speed
this up so we can get the survey go the
um the study going
faster that would be a question for doe
I think the 60 days effective date was
just the default from OS um I didn't
give them any instruction on on that
date so but I I would leave it up to the
department they have their own you know
task list and you know resource uh
constraint so I lead up to them I will
offer I don't know if ever source is in
the room but they had an idea to kind of
have it a more immediate approach where
they would uh allow for utilities to do
up to a certain minimum uh I think it
was like three uh micro grid projects
like begin them in the queue um but
there's still some undefined things that
uh I believe I don't want to speak for
anyone in particular but that the
department Department felt um you know
need needed some more uh thought behind
it before we launched something like
that but you'll
see uh let's see if I can find
it yeah it's uh line
19 uh letter C evaluation criteria and
approval process for utilities to
propose a limited number of microG good
pilot projects to the Public Utilities
Commission annually so that was sort of
like uh taking ever sources input and
you know making uh accommodations for
that pilot that pilot idea but I hear
what you're saying it this is this would
be a longer process than uh you know I
like immediate results but I can also
wait for stuff to happen later you
know unless anyone has a question
specifically for the representative um
or is tactical is it
you do okay because I I know that Doe
will want to get up and talk about uh
this as well so let's uh let's keep it a
question so the representative can
answer yeah representative wi my seat's
getting hotter and hotter thank you um
so um just on line 31 it says that they
will report the findings and
recommendations to the
legislature the entire legislature or
this committee who who do they report
this too I think traditionally it goes
to like the Senate President and the
speaker of the house and the governor
and the state librarian and okay all
right the house Clerk and then they
distribute it it's not specific in here
I see your
point go ahead thank you Mr chair thank
you representative Amon again um I sent
an email around to folks because when I
looked at the update that came to all of
us here on the committee my first
thought was that that a lot of times
what delays us is that we don't have any
funding source we don't have any way to
get things going and then we have to
come back around and convince everybody
that there's um value in doing something
that we just spent time studying so we
could determine that there was a value
so my thought is that I know that right
now we get um a newsletter a monthly
newsletter from doe which is chalk full
of links and references to federal
dollars that are available or federal
programs that we
um in the middle of putting in
applications for in order to help us
with transitioning our Energy Systems
and it's basically designed to give us a
leg up in money that we wouldn't be
putting in otherwise right so when I saw
this bill my first thought was do should
we add anything in here and we can ask
this of doe as well that um directs them
to make sure that they're referring to
those monies that are available with
Mind's Eye to this Pro you know to this
project so when they come back to us
with recommendations perhaps we can be
leveraging funding that we're trying to
secure now like try and marry them so
it's not up to us to try and figure out
how to put it together no I think that
would be a good addition um we had uh on
our on our Advanced nuclear commission
we had the department the US Department
of energy uh their office of nuclear
energy we had representatives from the
gain program which is a so there's a lot
of ederal funding for you know Advanced
nuclear but clean energy in general um
and so you I've heard firsthand that
that's the case
so all right thank
you we probably ask to we when they come
up here and everything okay and uh
that's it thank you representative and
um I guess by popular demand we could
ask Department of energy to step forward
and tell us the words that they put in
into this
amendment thank you Mr chairman and
members of the subcommittee for the
record my name is Chris Elms I'm the
Deputy Commissioner of the New Hampshire
Department of energy and I'm joined by
Mark Tuscano who's a utility analyst in
our regulatory Support Division um you
know we are are supportive of this
amendment um we think it's a really good
opportunity to resolve some of the
concerns that we had expressed uh you
know back in February with the
underlying Bill uh developing micro
grids is a there are a lot of technical
complexities that
um we believe that that the rirs of New
Hampshire would be best served by being
able to resolve prior to the
implementation of Pilots or um some new
filings related to micro grids you know
anything from the size of the micro grid
to the the ownership the relationship
between you know utilities and maybe you
know third- party uh folks um the
operation the
interconnection uh the relationship with
ISO cyber security there there are a a
lot of issues that that could come up
and that if they're not resolved prior
to that implementation of a pilot could
lead us to a situation where you know
rars would be on the hook for um you
know stranded costs related to a a a
pilot that didn't you know bear fruit so
uh we we worked with representative
Ammon on um developing you know this
directive uh that the department would
undertake an investigative proceeding
where we would look at you know all
these issues and more um you know
there's a lot of value in having that
legislative Direction uh in in you know
initiating an investigative proceeding
like this uh and we we think that it
would uh well served Rays to allow us to
uh take a look to work with the relevant
entities um you know like ISO like the
utilities various stakeholders uh and
then be able to bring forward
recommendations on how to resolve those
technical complexities um you know to
the question of Direction on on purpose
you know we are more agnostic as to why
somebody might want to do a micro grid
that' be interconnected to the grid I
think you know there are a lot of
benefits and they were highlighted we
wouldn't see that as necessarily our
role to tell you why they should do it
our role would be to tell you how to do
whatever folks want to do now some of
this it it might need further
legislation to implement Pilots it might
be something that we we have existing
authority to bring before the commission
or other companies might so that's why
um you know you saw a language that
directs us to make recommendations to
both the legislature and to the
commission um because you know there
there is just that possibility that it
would fall within existing authorities I
will say in on the topics of microG
grids there is not at this time a great
deal of institutional knowledge in the
state especially in the regulatory realm
on on a lot of these issues and that's
something that we see as a real
opportunity through this bill to develop
uh so that when we proceed with these
Pilots or whatever would come out of um
the invent the eventual investigative
proceeding that it's um off on the right
foot right that we have an opportunity
to you know take that purpose of a pilot
which really should be to develop
knowledge and you know learn some best
practices see what works for us what
doesn't work for us and then develop
that on a broader scale right a pilot
isn't just a pilot um as the end goal
you know so uh if if we don't you know
have a foundation of knowledge leading
into those Pilots we won't even really
know what to look for what to account
for and what data might be most useful
to us so we see this is a really uh good
opportunity that if the legislature
wants to to move the state in a
direction where micro grids are more
prevalent that this gives us the
direction to do the work um and have the
resources able to provide that
Foundation uh we do see this bill as
having as as allowing us to access the
resources we would need uh to to move
forward with that and um so we're we
happy to support it uh if you want to
move forward with a micro Grid
bill i' like to start off with a
question first
um at the risk of sounding
administrative
um us here and the folks here probably
have a fairly a fairly good idea of what
a micro grid is um I'm wondering I guess
the question is why in this amendment
would it not have been a um a more
descriptive
use of text if we if you could have led
with just a very brief uh description of
what micr grids are and maybe a
generalized listing of their pros and
cons so people would have a good idea of
what we're talking about uh and I I know
that the the purpose of the bill is to
go and investigate and see how it could
affect us here and what all the
implications are but what when the
legislator goes to vote on this not
everyone is going to know what a microG
grid really is just kind of wondering if
that might not be useful sure and and I
I think that's a good question and I
think it's a certainly a fair point to
raise you know that balance between um
what is necessary in statutory language
but what's useful in explaining that
right so that's that is something to to
think about and if if the legislature
wanted to add a sort of a a finding
section um that had maybe more of that
information we'd be happy to you know
work with folks on that uh you know we
see the language as it is here you know
purely from that implementation
statutory sense that we we know what
you're asking of us with this language
and we could Implement that in terms of
having the legislature have um further
Clarity for folks who um might not be as
uh you know focused on this issue area
uh we would see that as up up to the
legislature but would be happy to you
know work with folks on
that okay thank you perhaps something
that might be mentioned in a well speech
perhaps
Binky thank you Mr chair thank you Mr
Elms for taking my question um so I
appreciate what you said and I
appreciate the bill and um I think it's
it's a good thing for us to be doing my
question is it does come back to those
findings around the values of a micro
grid the why are we doing the microG
grid I know that we've had a lot of um
discussion around supporting nonprofits
who want to try and put in installations
that will help them lower their costs
because a lot of the publicly supported
State facilities and campuses around the
state uh were just hit really hard with
you know the the expenses of electricity
in the in the past year and so the
conversation comes back to I know with
the UNA un micro grid uh pilot which was
anticipated for some time when I was
first in the
legislature uh their point was to say
when when we have um a shortage or a
blackout or you know a short short
period of time after a storm where power
goes out we want to be self-sufficient
right we want to have all of our
primary um you know electric uh
infrastructure available to us so we
we're going to size it based on being
able to do that and and I think we have
other infrastructure like hospitals
right who have expressed the fact that
they would like some way to be more
secure so everybody right now pretty
much has um generators in New Hampshire
right we all know what that's like um
and I think I think of the mic micro
grid as a way to provide greater
security to people Beyond you know
beyond the generator right it's a it
it's so maybe Mr Tuscana could talk a
little bit about about micro grids in
terms of what value they bring to the
table if if a campus or a business or a
um what did you say uh you know
corporate entity uh has one available to
them so so that maybe we maybe the
legislature or this committee
specifically would be able to understand
when we get the report back what we
would be looking to solve for in terms
of where we might be interested in
having Pilots no I think that's a valid
point I think you know um the way that
we would look at this as I said before
you know the actual policy goal is
something that we'd be more agnostic on
but it this this legislation does list
you know uh reliability I don't know if
we use the word Brazilian it's a
interesting word but you know that as a
goal it clean energy it um lower costs
whatever we would see our role as really
helping to figure out what would enable
that micro grid for whatever purpose I
will ask uh Mark to speak a little bit
about his experience um and I I I think
you'll find it Illuminating um but but
it he can highlight some of the the the
the complexities and the challenges that
we're anticipating
um I think the only point I was trying
to make and I kind of went around the
world to make it was that I was
wondering whether we
should um in any way call out the idea
of a
state facility for a pilot you know as a
way to C cut cost for the state as well
you know I I think that's obviously up
to your discretion whether or not you
want to implement those I I we do we
took the position and and and would
continue take the position that we think
um an investigative proceeding would be
very beneficial in um leading to The
Next Step whatever that next step might
be and maybe it's a pilot that's um on
the you know that the state undertakes
maybe it's something else um that's
something that we would hope to discover
and and and hope our investigative
proceeding could illuminate maybe even
what a better path might be um I am
going to ask Mark just to talk a little
bit about what he's seen with this I I
think it would be helpful before you do
that so I make sure did you have a
question representative Wendy Thomas for
Chris or for uh no it's it's yeah for
Chris um so thank you thank you um my
question is is that there's no fiscal
note attached to this and we're
constantly hearing from the Department
of energy that you don't have the staff
you don't have the funds can you assure
us that you have the staff and the funds
to absorb this this committee and if not
can you estimate a cost please yeah so
uh I appreciate that question um just
sort of to you know reiterate a point
we' we've made we don't control the
fiscal note process so once an amendment
is adopted and brought forward uh Os or
LBA will reach out to us and provide us
a a fiscal worksheet which we'll fill
out and make uh some of those estimates
uh we would see an ability to um assess
the costs of a consultant to rate payers
you know you know through this under our
existing statutory Authority which we
use uh in a variety of circumstances
with with proceedings um I couldn't give
you an estimate today on that um we'd
have to talk to our budget folks uh but
but we would see that we have the
statutory authority to do so I can't
tell you what the number
is thank
you I've got I just want to follow up to
with tech
question can you at least assure us that
the answer to
the physical note would not be
indeterminate well you know uh we do uh
pursue you know competitive solicitation
for consultants and obviously in the
energy field there is a uh it's a it's a
very Niche um you know area of expertise
involved with with microgrid so I can't
tell you that there's a um there there's
just a service where we can go and say
this will cost $100,000 exactly uh we
would undergo competitive solicitation
so unfortunately the answer would
probably be indeterminate but we would
probably be able to give you a range of
estimates based on what we've seen for
similar
Consultants thank
you thank you Mr
chairman so following up on on a
question representative McGee asked
representative Ammon we're looking at 60
days from enactment and then another 120
days from that for this proceeding to
spin up so that's a half a year is a
half a year I me do you really need half
a
year well um you know the more time the
better and I guess from our perspective
we we do see this as you know um a
balance between speed and having that
Firm Foundation to move forward with
with future things now look New
Hampshire is not an easy place to
procure uh consultants and they go
through that process and I think you're
all well aware of what we have to go
through with a governor and councel
process um and then in just the state
procurement and that really can take
several months um from you know scoping
out the investigation then creating an
RFP to uh select the right you know find
the right attributes and the right
expertise going out for an appropriate
amount of time reviewing the bids that
come in selecting the proper uh you know
consultant balancing their expertise and
cost coming through the governor and
Council process getting that approval
starting the investigation um you know
that that really does eat up a lot of
time we see the benefit of having that
lead time as being able to frontload a
lot of that work so once the
investigation is initiated we don't have
to say um okay let's now spend the next
four months getting a consultant before
we can really even dive into this um you
know I I think if you wanted to move up
the initiation of it it's something that
you could do we would ask I think for
probably more than a year at that point
unless you you know we could rush it we
can we can get the job done and whatever
time uh is given to us it'll just be a a
product that is the product of a rushed
you know process so again it's not meant
to delay anything it's just you know the
stay process is what it is and we want
to work within that to be effective for
repairs just keep it under
10,000 just that'll be uh quite oh yeah
yeah then we wouldn't have to go to
governor and
Council I'll give you just since I'm
here I I'll make it make it real quick
uh but we are doing an investigation
right now into interconnect as you
probably know inter interconnection
procedures for the state um and to
Chris's Point these things take time you
know you have participants you got
feedback you got to solicit comments and
everything else and that's after you
have the consultant on board and we do
not have anybody on staff right now
that's well verse enough in this uh to
do it justice based on the scope I give
you a little bit of my background you
appreciate where I come from um spent
about 30 years at Brook Haven National
Laboratory that's a department of energy
research facility um so we are all we
weren't a micro grid but my scientists
wanted us to be a microG grid I was on a
facility side of the house so the energy
and Facilities keeping the lights on and
and the steam flowing all the good
things like that and uh we're 60
megawatt load so it's a big facility and
the plan was my scientists that worked
there the PHD type folks wanted to have
a microG grid and they were after me for
many many years to get a micro grid
going it's no easy task for all the
things that you've already heard a
little bit and you'll find out from part
of this investig ation and technically
it's not difficult it's more the
Regulatory and the the the process
that's the real difficult part and I
just want to mention that it's to my
understanding there are only two states
right now that even have tariff
Provisions for microG grids and that's
California and Hawaii so this is up and
cominging it's new quote unquote even
though micro grids have been around
forever every hospital as you mentioned
before everybody's got a backup
generator technically is kind of a micro
grid anyway but now you need to come up
with the process and the regulatory
framework that allow these things to
work and function without causing
problems so that's where most of the
time will most likely be spent um but I
I did spend a considerable about amount
of time trying to put those things in
play and as I mentioned the technical
part was actually much easier than the
uh the regulatory type
stuff represent McGee thank you uh Mr
chairman yes and thank you Mr tscan for
taking my question um my question is
around whether or not you you think this
this report should
include uh where the greatest benefits
of H of placing micro grids within the
state whether it's by sector or by
region would be included in any results
that we would receive which would be
helpful to us I think because we we've
got public we've got private sector
we've got individuals we've got you
know so having an idea of where where we
should go next might be something that
your report could help us with it's a
very good question and it's a very good
point I think you know the balance
between the scope of the investigation
so that it can be effective and you know
Finding as much information as possible
you know the uh the the proceeding could
look at every possible aspect but but
every possible aspect might not be
necessary to move forward with microG
grids once we're able to you know focus
on those things that are the true
hurdles so I think we'd want to have
some further conversations about whether
or not geography is one of those sort of
um hurdles where it would be best to
overcome or if that would be economic
and sort of the the scope of what we're
talking about here um I don't know Mark
if you have anything to say on that
topic um I I agree I think that would be
nice if we could find you know that
could be part of it is to where would be
the biggest benefit I mean that's the
intent of of doing this in the first
place
um in past discussions we had you know
resiliency is a word that nobody can yet
fully Define as you all know in terms of
a metrics um but the idea that you would
Target micr grids for critical type
facilities as you mentioned before
hospitals or or security type things and
things of that nature um in my mind this
you know you you get into as Chris
mentioned before you know what direction
would be from a you know we're AG
agnostic so to speak um in terms of it
we just want to identify the issues that
have to be addressed in terms of
priorities and where they would go I you
that's an area that I'd be
uh not a place that I could really weigh
in on and just to go on that I I do
think you know that's something that
might fall into evaluation criteria that
the Pu might want to look at um when
approving micr grids and how that plays
into reliability or whatever the goal
might be um I I I could see some
conversation about including geography
as as part of that followup thank you
thank you Mr chairman uh and the
followup would be to go back to the
beginning of where I mentioned that I
had sent a note out to the committee
just stating that I wanted to know if
doe could also be responsible for or
whether we have to put it in here to
make it so uh figuring out whether there
is any money that's coming from the
federal government to the state now that
could be leveraged because it seems like
the timing of this bill may be just off
enough that you know my understanding is
the IRA funding goes for 10 years and in
other words it's designed to provide
some consistency so people can put in
projects at various stages but I would
think that it would be really helpful if
this bill also instructed the doe to let
us know whereas you're a lot more
familiar with whether there are federal
dollars that could be leveraged for any
initial pilot to make it more of a
reality so yeah absolutely good question
I don't think you need to include that
in the in the language we are looking at
those opportunities uh if you if you
wanted to direct us to do so that that
that's perfectly okay we are constantly
looking for federal opportunities we
understand the mission and uh know that
uh New Hampshire is a state where we
want to you know leverage opportunities
where we can find them um you know
coming to mind you know I think you
raised a good point we just got uh 7
million 6.6 million for the what is it
the 40101 d uh grid resiliency grants
those are fiveyear we got the first two
years of a five-year Grant um you know
there are other opportunities where
something like this might be able to you
know say uh bid into an RFP or or or
what have you um I don't know any off
the top of my head where mic that are
micro grid uh specific but we have a lot
more folks looking at it than just me uh
so you know I think there's uh that's
something we would definitely take a
look at in this realm and and across
sort of
energy I have uh go ahead representative
Wendy Thomas then I'll have Co after
that go ahead thank you thank you Mr
chair um and this may be a question for
um Keith uh um representative Aman I'm
sorry um on line 26 it says the role of
the micr grids in supporting economic
growth clean energy Innovation does that
include solar wind Hydro is that
considered a contributors to these micro
grids yeah uh you know we we uh would
see that those Technologies as following
you know as as as inclusive or being
included within the bill yeah okay thank
you my question hopefully is not
regarded as a loaded question um but it
just came to mind for New
Hampshire this if if this is approved
the the the study uh and the Consultants
that you have the high
is going to cost a bit of
money are
we that confident that we're just not
studying a pig and a poke where New
Hampshire really will never be
interested in a microid or are we put or
are we putting together uh a a a study
where we are serious that we can
actually in install microids here in in
the foreseeable future and and I don't
mean that to be negative I just want to
make sure that we're just not doing this
because people want to have a study
because it's going to cost money and I
want to make sure that we're putting
money into in in into a study where we
really think we have a good case uh I
think we do but I mean I I just want to
make sure that we do have a good case
that when we're done with the study that
we're actually G to do something it's a
good definitely a fair question um and
one that I would answer by saying that
passing this bill would be clear
direction to the department that the
legislature wants us to pursue you know
um fixing or or or looking into the
complexities related to microG grids and
we would take that very seriously and
and look for those opportunities to
implement them uh in the best interest
of New Hampshire uh micr grids as as
representative Ammon talked about do
have a lot of promise and and a lot of
benefits and and of of course there is
some risk
that they don't work out or that there
is something that doesn't um fit for New
Hampshire but we would take a a a very
um hard look and and we would have this
statutory direction to uh you know find
all those complexities and act in the
public
interest yes you would but what do you
think you know I I think there are a lot
of there are a lot of benefits here that
um that are worth exploring and I think
the the promise is
probably something that you know finding
out whether or not we can overcome the
hurdles is a worthy
Endeavor thank you to make sure we put
the people's money to good
use representative Winnie Thomas thank
you Mr chair um you mentioned um uh
Hawaii and California already have Micro
grids do you have any idea of how many
or the percentage if that's if it's
measured that way U no I do not I just
know that they finally got some tariffs
regulatory in process uh to help and
even with that they're still working
through the Growing Pains of those kinds
of things I I do want to say that uh you
know micro grids it's interesting
because I've been doing this for a long
time it's not a New Concept every
college campus on the plan in every
hospital like I mentioned before anybody
that can Island and be on their own and
start up on their own of course um
that's technically a micro grid so
clearly we know there are benefits of
them the question is often and I have
draw fulls of my old job of evaluating
total energy facilities so we could be
independent or partially independent and
and it's there are a lot of long-term
planning assumptions so these things are
not quick they will take time to to
address all the issues is where where
I'm going with this even though we would
like it to move a little faster um but I
I think clearly it is's enough desire
and there are there are a lot of
benefits in certain cases for them so we
we'll go through this investigation with
our eyes wide open for
sure follow up thank you um just um for
my own education can you have Micro
grids within micro GD
grids I don't see why not um you know
like I said technically if there's more
than one it's a micro grid right well
you were talking about an island well
islanding yeah islanding is when you
segregate from the utility um and you
can run all by yourself and you're
completely divorced and and you can stay
there and and then of course the key is
to be able to sink back in right or in
and out that's where the biggest
problems come for the utilities where
they got to manage that and that's where
you get into a lot of the technical and
and then also you know contractual type
stuff regulatory things like how much do
you have to pay for this backup power
and the ability so in any case yes you
can have mic micro grids within a micro
grid technically okay thank you
representative
and thank you uh thank you for taking
the question um I was wondering how I
going to segue this in but in in the
study would doe also be looking
at they be Rec recommending yes no
different ones but if there is a pilot
plant generator would they be allowed to
be separate from the grid for like
demand things residenti but when things
go down I'm looking at Capital being put
in from outside investors and all of a
sudden we we're P um
producing electricity then all of a
sudden the grid goes down and ISO says
you got to dump it to us for a pilot
plant to put the money in I can only see
it going forward and this is Segway off
uh represent Doug
Thomas's the money is if they
can go on by themselves and then we can
do the the rest of them separate is it a
possible way yeah no and I I think
that's a that that is a really good
question and and part of why we support
the investigative proceeding uh as
happening before the pilots because it
can help us you know as a state
determine the best way to um approach
that relationship between the micro grid
the state and then the region right the
grid that were're a part of uh so you
know I think that that's something that
we would have to look at as part of the
investigative
proceeding um thank you again and I
invite anyone else interested in joining
in the frey thank you very much I I see
uh Mr lado from ever
source so I'm sure he's going to um be
wholeheartedly for this an expert in the
prey good afternoon uh again Michael
Lata representing ever Source um I'll
keep my comments uh brief first of all
just wanted to really thank
representative Ammon for reaching out uh
he did uh talk to me about some of the
concerns that we had raised with the
underlying Bill we had a great
conversation walking through um you know
what he's trying to achieve and our
experience on micro grids and uh we
offered uh some options uh uh in terms
of a pathway forward um so one of which
was a investigation by the department of
energy and I think the legislation does
a good job of of laying out the areas of
uh of interest that one would want to
explore uh we had suggested uh a little
bit of a different approach um you know
we were coming from this where as the
statutes exist today there's nothing
that prohibits a utility from proposing
a micro grid to the
um Public Utilities Commission so one of
the challenges that we have is because
um as uh Deputy Commissioner Elm said
this is you know there's not a lot of
experience in the state and this is
somewhat novel um you know how you
present that at the commission um uh
creates a little bit of risk so
typically the utility goes in for a rate
case every so often and that's to
recover the cost of their prudently
incurred um spending on the capital side
uh and the expense side and it's sort of
an after Thea look where we haven't had
micro grids really in New Hampshire this
is something new uh you can go in for
sort of a pre-authorization you would
file a plan uh have the commission and
and various stakeholders weigh in on
that and then you would go out and
actually construct and then you get the
cost recovery after assuming that your
expenses are your spending is prudent so
what we had suggested was um simply to
set up a framework that the commission
would review uh micro grid proposals by
the utilities as part of our planning
framework um and uh understand you know
the department and other stakeholders
were you know wanted to do a little bit
more information gathering um I think
representative McGee um you know you
raised uh several good issues our focus
is really on um reliability uh would use
this as a planning tool where we would
identify areas of of poor system
reliability do an evaluation if a micro
grid uh made sense to support as as you
talked about critical facilities in the
area whether those are uh hospitals
police stations University uh State
facilities uh and then of course you
know what are the costs associated with
that versus a traditional sort of wires
um uh solution so uh that was that was
our uh suggested approach was sort of
developing the framework and the
criteria that you know what would the
utility have to present in terms of
information um to the Public Utilities
Commission and then what would be their
criteria for reviewing and we tried to
mirror it a little bit off of um
existing statute 374 G which allows for
utility investment in distributed energy
resources so we kind of use that
definition uh we did pull in uh a
version of the federal us Doe definition
of of micro grid because I think it is
important um to to have sort of a
definition around what a micro grid is
um and so so that was uh some of the
concepts that we had had discussed um
but certainly we understand that there's
sort of an interest uh in moving forward
with with further investigation we agree
that um you know there's a lot of
questions here these are very
complicated from uh both a regulatory
but I would add from uh in our
experience extremely complicated from an
engineering standpoint the ability to to
isolate and control uh and make it
essentially seamless for the customers
and also not have um and also the
integration with the larger distribution
system there's a lot of work that goes
into that uh which is why we felt that
it was appropriate as part of uh the
utility planning process so um happy to
answer any questions uh certainly
support uh the language that's uh in
front of you on the
investigation and uh look forward to to
answering um I'll lead with with a
question um from a technical standpoint
since you did mention it was extremely
complicated from engineering point of
view have you been or is there available
I know there's conferences from time to
time around the world there must be one
involving uh micro grids or at least um
ones that utilities send people to has
there been any uh presentations or
discussions with California or Hawaii to
find out what their engineering uh
challenges were that you could glean
from that and see if they even apply
here
um so I I'm I'm not familiar with uh
California and Hawaii I I would say we
do have at ever Source uh experience
with developing and managing micro grids
in Connecticut and Massachusetts um and
so you know certainly if the legislation
moves forward we would make uh you know
those folks available to work with the
department and discuss their experiences
on an engineering standpoint um and a
planning standpoint so we could
certainly offer those folks as as
technical experts in support of a um of
an
investigation uh my followup yes but you
said that was extremely complicated so
I'm just kind of curious if there are
ways that we can lower the risk um by
consolidating information from other
states as well as the ones you uh
interested in and and and again are
there conferences that utilities do
attend that these types of things could
be uh talked about I'm I'm not
suggesting that we you know send you to
one specifically but I'm just kind of
curious if they have them around here
and that people can kind combine their
ideas I'm just trying to lower Risk by
sharing ideas sure no of of course and
our folks attend um you know numerous
conferences and present at conferences
on our own experience and and what when
I speak to sort of the the engineering
technical um uh complexities it's it's
you know the actual engineering of of
the physical poles and wires and
distributed uh resources and having
everything communicate at a central
location usually in a utility control
room sort of the disconnect and and all
that that goes into it um and we yeah we
we have folks who who are you know very
you know that's what they do for a
living thank
you next oh thank you nice he's giving
me's G me all right um membership has
its privileges okay so um my question
was around whether or not eversource had
any involvement in the UNH pilot or
whether that was something that was
being done specifically with the
university like who was involved with
trying to pull that together and do you
have any idea why it fell apart because
I I never heard it just stopped yeah uh
this predates my time with the company
uh but and I I'd be happy to get you
more information that'd be great um but
but we were involved in the development
of that and I as I sit here don't have
the full story on why it didn't move
forward but um I know we were involved
working with the the university on that
okay great thank you represent Winnie
Thomas thank you um you mentioned that
eversource has micro grids in
Connecticut and Massachusetts I think
you both said um
so does eversource have any kind of and
this is piggy pigtailing Pig pigtailing
I don't know piggy backing sorry on
representative Doug Thomas's um question
are there is there a document of best
practices for these micr grids in
Connecticut and
Massachusetts
um I I can certainly share the
Regulatory and statutory framework that
um help support the development of micro
grids if there's a sort of technical
best practices document I'll I'm happy
to ask the
team I would think there would be
something I mean that's standard isn't
it to have best practices identified
sure I I just not sure I I can
appreciate that thank
you any other questions for yes
representative Colman not not a question
but to answer a question from our chair
I was just looking there is a microgrid
knowledge conference uh it'll be held in
Baltimore in
April and you're volunteering
right
thank
you sorry anybody else would like to
speak on this
issue okay seeing none I'll open it up
for discussion amongst our subcommittee
members um as to the merits of this
amendment and if we want to recommend
going forward to recommend adoption of
of this
amendment
any discussion of course go ahead of
course yes well the two things that I
took down for consideration of whether
we want to modify it at all um is you
know this is an act it says it's an act
requiring the department of energy to
initiate a microid study and um I would
want to modify that language to say that
helps the state of New Hampshire make
micro grids a reality because I want it
to be Tethered to us actually having a
concrete outcome what line is it um uh
it's it's right under the line three you
know the N act right so so if rather
than descript the description just being
vague and
saying uh that the really the point of
the State of New Hampshire is to make
micro grids a reality right to figure
out how to get it from Soup To
Nuts
um and then there was also some
discussion early about whether we should
have a finding section in order to
Define either the value of or the the
description of micro grids it sounds
like if the department of energy is
saying California and Hawaii have Micro
grids and eversource is saying we're
supporting microG grids in Connecticut
and mass then maybe the definition of
microG grids is different depending on
who you're talking to you know based on
size or or whatever it's supporting or
whose it is so I think it might be
valuable for us to Circle back to try
and have a finding section that
discusses what we mean by micro grids
right what's a micro grid going to do
for New Hampshire and uh how can it be
used and who can use it it would be
helpful this this this would requ this
would require um work another amendment
another iteration and we'd have to come
back and meet again just to vote on
it well if we agreed to the amendment
and we could circulate it amongst the
folks on the committee we could bring it
to the executive session and make make
our recommendation for the vote on the
amendment
when it comes when it gets voted out of
committee we could the subcommittee
would still have to formally make a
recommendation uh at some time if you're
suggesting we meet five minutes before
the executive session no so you're
saying none of what we heard today we
we're either going to take this or
that's it well that's that's what I'm
asking if if we make any
changes uh we what what would be we
wouldn't we couldn't vot we couldn't
vote on something that was wasn't yeah
an official draft of this correct y
that's that's what I'm saying so I I I
guess the question is is can we can can
we live with this the way it is I think
the Bill's okay as it is I'm not not
saying and then in in in the uh in the
executive session or even in in
legislation we could we could even
modify the amendment if needed that's
true all right yeah then I'm I'm fine
with moving it forward as is these are
just uh this is just word smithing
honestly we have a
I see s Mr Sam Evans Brown hasn't spoken
at all and so I highly unusual so I want
to give him
next go
ahead if uh folks are looking for a
definition of micro grid there was a US
dooe definition of micro Grid in uh the
suggested language that eversource had
put forward and so I have it right here
if folks I happy to email to the
committee if that's
helpful
sure represent am you had a a
comment ditto
okay so we can take care of that
representative Wendy Thomas thank you Mr
chair um you know I I'm going to vote
for this um I think it's it's a pretty
uh descriptive example of what we want
um my concern however are is the time
frame if you add everything together the
60 days the 120 days the year that comes
to 1.5 years and I think you brought
that up
too um that's just one of my concerns
it's not enough to sync it for me but um
I do have concerns about the time um I
do have concerns about the fiscal note
um lacking um again I mean if if it is
going to cost money to do the right
thing then we have to do that and then
finally um I have concerns about and I
brought it up in a question on line 26
that clean energy Innovation I just
would like to see that uh defined I'm
big on
definitions What defined Define yeah
more specifically because I asked if it
included solar and wind and and and the
answer was yes it was but it's not
defined here so it feels like they don't
have to consider it if they don't want
to
um well I
think there was a unofficial effort
going around to try and have a
definition of clean energy but I think
it was decided that uh rather than than
narrow it down that it would be better
to just um leave it open so that we know
it we know it definitely includes
renewable energy we we know that and uh
possibly even asmrs but um
I think I think the's suggestion or or
intent was to to leave
it generalized specific so that no
one one energy source was was picked out
in other words it wouldn't be just solar
it wouldn't be just wind or just battery
um no and I I can appreciate that and
but we you're talking about clean energy
but this is clean energy
Innovation and it's the Innovation that
has me a little concerned again it's not
enough for me to sync the bill and I'm
sure the Senate if they're not happy
with it they'll they'll get rid of it
but that's just one of my
concerns thank you uh although I'm not
officially member of the subcommittee I
just want to speak to something that
representative McGee said and I'm going
to preface it by I once had a software
engineering job where the first thing I
did was a feasibility study for the
product they hired me for and my answer
was no no and uh as a result I was laid
off very
quickly um so an honest man is what
you're saying
so when when I think about um saying
that that we're going to require the
part the doe to initiate a microG grid
study with a goal toward uh actually
implementing micr grids it's possible
that the conclusion of the study would
be well actually these are infeasible or
the costs of doing so are rather
prohibitive so I think it's probably
better to not actually state that goal I
think we all want micro grids but I
think it's better to not State the the
that goal in the um in the uh enacting
Clause see any comment thank you uh
representative Corman mentioned mine and
thank it came from that
side okay well I um I agree I I think we
have enough here in this amendment to go
forward with a a recommendation I
certainly would would support it I'm
sure that by the time it reaches uh
Prime Time there might be additional
amendments that might come forward after
goes through committee and uh you know
whatnot but I think we have enough here
to uh to you uh recommend so unless
there's an objection from our four
subcommittee members uh I would like to
open the uh executive session on the
subcommittee and call for a vote on the
motion to um recommend um house
Amendment
23-23
21h uh for recommendation to the um uh
Science Tech and energy committee so
with that I would like um uh how about
representative PL Could you um call a
vote and ask for our votes
please by name yes uh thank you chair on
U I'm looking at the amendment there we
go Amendment
-23
21h I would recommend
accepting uh the
amendment and I will vote Yes on
that yes as well
mge uh
yes and the chair votes
yes so with a vote of 40 we will
recommend this amendment to the uh
Science Tech energy committee at their
next executive session any further
comments nothing else uh I'll declare
this uh work session
closed and thank you for your
inputs
scheduled meeting the we did have a we
did have a date scheduled in case this
was a spill over we don't need one so
the uh notice of October 23rd I will I
will have
cancelled go on and enjoy your
vacation